if you want to know how people like Jeff
Bezos Oprah Winfrey and Simon Sonic
became visionaries then this video is
for you that's something that you have
to sort of steel yourself for discipline
and teach over time what is the truest
highest vision that you hold for
yourself a vision is having a crystal
clear sense of what the finish line
looks like but no idea of how far away
it is
once I believe nature that's happened my
one word is believed and I believe in
you I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
onto the world I started the one rule
series because I've consumed a ton of
content and in all of the top tens that
I do I wanted to pull together some of
the rules that came up over and over and
over again and smoosh them into one
video just for you guys
till today we're gonna learn how you can
become a visionary
enjoy
[Music]
I asked everybody to not think in two to
three-year timeframes but to think in
five to seven-year timeframes to not
think about when somebody says to me
congratulate Sam azan on a good quarter
which is a very common thing to say you
meet somebody they're being nice they
looked at your financial results for the
quarters a good quarter I say thank you
but what I'm thinking to myself is that
quarter all that those quarterly results
were actually pretty much fully baked
about three years ago and so like today
I'm working on you know a quarter that
is going to happen in 2020 not next
quarter next quarter for all practical
purposes is done already and it's
probably been done for a couple of years
and so if you start to think that way it
changes how you spend your time how you
plan where you put your energy and and
your ability to look around corners gets
better so many things improve if you can
take a long term by the way it's not
natural for humans so it's a it's a
discipline that you have to build the
the kind of you know get rich slowly
schemes are not big sellers on
infomercials you know it's and so that's
something that you have to sort of steel
yourself for discipline and teach
over time what drives you to keep
working so hard you could you know you
and I are in the 60s category and so
when you're in your 60s you know you've
lived more than you're gonna live
yeah a listicle e so when you realize
you've lived more than you're gonna live
you can say why not relax a little bit
why not just ease up why have you
decided to even work harder than you did
before because I think David that
everybody you know the thing that works
for me all these years whether it was
the magazine or which I still have or
whether it was the show I could I
understood that there's a common
denominator in the human experience and
I want the same thing you want which is
the same thing you want and you want
what we all want is to be able to live
out the truest highest expression of
ourselves as a human being that doesn't
end until you take your last breath
what is the truest highest vision that
you hold for yourself no matter where
you are in your life there's always the
next level there's always the next level
to the last breath so I feel that I
always knew that I would get be done
with the show when I felt like oh I've
said as much as I could say here on this
platform and then how will I be used if
they were if there were a theme song to
my life
Amazing Grace would be one of them and
keep on using me to use me up would be
another one you know that bill with
their song so I feel that until you have
used your value as a human being you're
not done people are always talked about
visions and missions and all of this
stuff and when people ask me like what
example should I look - like what
company should I'm like here's an
organization with a vision a cause it
was founded with a cause it's an
entrepreneurial venture it's America is
an experiment it's an entrepreneurial
venture where a bunch of people got
together and decided we needed to start
our own country because there were
certain obstacles that were getting in
the way of a vision that we had of a
better kind of country but a kind of
company right and they stated it right
out of the beginning all men are created
equal in
with these unalienable rights among
amongst which include life liberty and
pursuit of happiness and it's not a it's
not just a competitive statement like to
be the best to be the most respected
that's not what it was and I'm amazed
how many companies start their visions
or missions with those that terribly
egocentric language it was an ideal and
the amazing thing is is we've been good
at it and bad at it in our history but
it's endured for 240 plus years because
we fundamentally believe that we are at
our best when we're pursuing that but it
is an ideal we will never actually
achieve all people are equal but we will
die trying and that's the point and it's
the same for a company which is true
vision inside a company is something
that has nothing to do with your product
it is an ideal to which you will attempt
to build an advanced that ideal through
your company with your product you'll
never achieve the ideal but you'll die
trying and this is what gives our work
meaning this is what it gives our lives
purpose right the difference between
vision and a goal is the finish line a
goal is 26.2 miles
you can simply count the metrics and
know when you've completed your goal a
vision is having a crystal-clear sense
of what the finish line looks like but
no idea of how far away it is and it's
and the reality is you will spend your
entire life never actually crossing the
finish line but the joy that every
marathon you complete you feel like
you're getting closer every milestone
that you accomplish makes you feel like
you're getting closer and closer to the
ideal and this is what gives our life in
our work meaning most people have goals
in life and we've been broke think you
got to be goal-oriented that's the first
mistake yes you need goals but there's
something far beyond goals which is what
all successful people have and that's a
vision it's a vision for the future see
the here's it is you see things as they
are but not worse than they are yeah
which is what a lot of people do yeah
they say oh it's so terrible they tell
themselves this wild story about why
they can't take action and in truth the
story they tell themselves is exactly
what holds them back from being
successful oh great it's that both story
that stops from acting like and they're
all just so
I mean they play the blame game they
complain they justify and it stops them
from moving forward so see things as
they are not worse than they are
yeah and then see them better than they
are yeah and make them that way look at
a Gandhi right you survived hunger
strikes in the United the country not
because he had a goal for free and yet
he had a vision of a free India Nelson
Mandela all those years in jail on
vision yeah it's Richard Branson who's a
friend of mine who I only sponsors me my
speaking to our city he's a visionary
Bill Gates they're all visionaries and
the best example consider in Hollywood
is a guy like James Cameron now here's
the trap
James camera is probably the greatest
visionary of all time in filmmaking that
we do a great Darren he was the food on
Diane Sawyer and they asked him a
question of what are you owe your
success to and what he said was this I
said really really high goals so even if
I fall short I'm still doing great and
people thought that was pretty profound
and I actually believed in that too it's
not true though see what's happening is
this James Cameron is not a goal setter
he's a visionary he just doesn't realize
because he's running unconscious
strategy himself you said the try said
Jim's kennels are really just the goals
your vision for avatar he'd say oh of
course I will
did get all excited me tell you how
nothing was gonna stop him from making
this movie the fact that it took ten
years and ran 200 million over budget he
put money in himself or that's not what
goal setters do bowl setters will set a
goal gets tough and they abandon it and
I can't overemphasize that distinction
that's number one is vision the first
thing that you need to do is you start
you define what success looks like for
you and it's not ten million dollars in
the bank I'm sorry it needs to be
something bigger a big what if some
resource unders ten million dollars in
the bank to me well yeah I mean the
problem was saying it's ten million
dollars in the bank is that when you
finally get to the ten million dollars
typically those people feel pretty
bankrupt because that's what you're
saying and that's what you're seeing
you'll absolutely absolutely and so you
know once you define it for yourself I
think the key is how do you then trick
yourself Donny into feeling successful
every single day you know I've got a
daughter the plays were lacrosse she's
nine years old if I said to her I'm only
cheering for you when you score a goal
how do you think she'd feel during the
game she wouldn't play very well that's
for sure so you've got to figure out how
do you cheer for yourself and how do you
feel successful while you're playing the
game because it's not all about the goal
okay and are there any tools to cheer
for myself give me today I want to feel
better inside I'm at home I'm watching
I'm either somebody that's got the
millions of dollars and it's not feeling
good or I don't have those millions of
dollars I'm just not feeling good I'm
worried about the economy around me so
you want to do what you need to do is
you have to decide okay this is where
I'm going I'm going for the big vision
of what success is
now do a head-fake with yourself and say
okay let's just say that I'm actually
already there I have the ten million
dollars in the bank I'm you know saving
the world whatever it is that your
version of successes what are three
things that I would change about this
day to day how would I live it today if
I already had all that stuff what time
would I wake up who's my first phone
call to what did I eat for breakfast
start living as that success vision now
every genius entrepreneur has an
eccentric vision so their possibility
Rian's
they are the people who said you know
well here's the way the industry has
always been and here's the way the
status quo is but here's what we're
going to do what's coming to the top of
my mind right now as I record this is
uber so you've got Travis County AK and
literally through that single app I mean
they don't own any taxis they don't own
any cars they don't really have any
inventory but through that single app
uber disrupted the entire industry of
that level of Transportation and so you
know these people these genius
entrepreneurs come up with a
ridiculously disruptive idea that is
absolutely eccentric in its vision and
that's why people call them crazy and
I'll simply say to you if your vision is
not routinely called crazy then perhaps
your vision isn't big enough and
disruptive enough and we changed the
world when we change the game Thomas
Alva Edison once made a very nice
statement he said genius is 1%
inspiration and 99% perspiration
we may have an inspiration in a heart
but 1% strong
on burning Inferno of an inspiration but
unless that inspiration is put into
action dedicated committed hard work
that 99% perspiration we are not going
to be able to achieve what we want to
achieve and so also when we talk about
dealing with our bad habits success is
1% inspiration and 99% perspiration
we need that inspiration but based on
the foundation of that inspiration we
have to put an dedicated committed hard
work that 99% perspiration what's
amazing is that 99% perspiration is
based on the foundation of that 1%
inspiration if the foundation of a
building is in place the very first
thing that we make when it comes to
building a structure a house a beautiful
edifice or a mansion is they put the
foundation in place if the foundation is
in place if it's strong and robust
then all the building block is the
bricks the cement the mortar the steel
can go on and form a beautiful structure
for us to live in for us to dwell in and
so also that 1% inspiration is the
foundation of that 99% perspiration
imagine if you're very inspired to
change if you're very inspired to give
up some of your bad habits but you don't
put that hard work that 99% perspiration
what good is that inspiration or imagine
if you keep putting 99% of perspiration
that hard work that effort the dedicated
commitment but if you don't have that
inspiration to do it in the right
direction and sustain it and get it a
higher shelf life what good is that hard
work and perspiration
therefore success comes by a balance of
the two inspiration which acts as the
foundation and perspiration which acts
as the building blocks to build upon
that foundation I once read a very
interesting
Japanese proverb it said action without
vision is a nightmare if you simply keep
acting without having the right vision
the result is a nightmare and it said
vision without action is a daydream if
you simply have a vision and you don't
act upon it all you have as a result is
a daydream
I have rephrased it for our discussion
here today
perspiration without inspiration is a
nightmare but inspiration without
perspiration is a daydream you need to
be insanely stubborn about the mission
insanely stubborn about the why you're
doing things but really flexible about
the how and I think you need to have
that stubbornness especially as an
entrepreneur because when you're getting
started you're gonna get so much
pushback right what you create your
product your service won't be really
great at the start and so it'll be hard
to get people to buy from you you'll
have people around you friends family
co-workers you know people in your
community telling you that it's not
gonna work out you're telling yourself
that sometimes this is crazy and it's
not gonna work out and so everything
around you is saying that this is crazy
and that maybe it's not the smartest
thing to do right
I mean entrepreneur is really the smart
thing to do it might be the best thing
to do but what we do is we create a
world that does not exist like the best
entrepreneurs have a vision for a world
that they want to create that doesn't
exist yet so from a practical
perspective it doesn't make sense like
we're doing something that has never
been done before you guys need to be
doing something that's never been done
before
right like you can model some success
but at some point you have to find your
own path and when you go and create your
own path it's not practical it's not
logical because it doesn't exist yet you
have to go and create it and so you need
to have that stubbornness for the
mission for the vision for what end
objective you're trying to create
because of all of the pushback and
negativity and zero progress you're
gonna make at the beginning if you don't
have that stubbornness if you aren't
willing to say no this is going to work
out
to yourself and to the people around you
who are naysayers then you're gonna quit
which most entrepreneurs end up doing
they they quit they don't have enough
stubbornness for where they want to go
the flexibility that was about how you
go and accomplish it I want to make this
world better here's how I want it to
look like here's here's what I want to
change in the industry but how you go
and do it should be flexible and this is
where I think too many entrepreneurs are
too stubborn it has to be this specific
way and this way only so you spend all
this time making this perfect plan right
the perfectionist you want to make this
perfect plan and you're all your time
was working on this plan this is exactly
how it's gonna play out
no matter how much planning you do it's
never gonna go according to that plan
every successful business look at how
they started it's not how they started
that led them to their ultimate success
sometimes it's a radical shift in their
plan sometimes it's a minor shift in
their plan but it always has to change
just look at any company look at how
they started look at Starbucks they
started selling just beans you couldn't
get coffee going into a Starbucks they
would only sell you the beans
BMW started selling airplanes that's why
their logo is an airplane propeller
you know Wrigley is the gun company
started selling other household products
and gum was just used as a as a giveaway
that if you buy X packs of this other
product we'll give you some gum and the
eventually became the gum company rights
like it changes so often and too many
entrence are stuck on that has to be
this specific way and if you're not
listening to the market if you're not
combining what you love with what the
market wants you're never going to get
to the success that you're after
and so that insane stubbornness for the
vision but total flexibility for how you
accomplish it that's what's really
important as an entrepreneur what you
say in the book is that development
begins when you have the first vision of
what you can be correctly you can't
write a movie unless you know what the
movie's supposed to be about that's what
development is sometimes we get so
frustrated in our lives but we have to
go back and say wait a minute do I
understand what the big idea of my life
is supposed to be if my life is a story
that I have to know the point of my
story and sometimes what happens when we
start developing a movie
the producers may have one vision of
what the movie's supposed to be and the
studio has another version
and then the movie becomes nothing
because there's not clarity of idea so
with our life we have to have clarity of
what we're supposed to do what do we
believe we're called to do in this life
and in that way it gives our whole
development process more shape now I've
got a special bonus clip with Lois house
on how to be a visionary but before
getting to that the question of the day
I have for you is what is your big
vision for your company what is it that
you want to build what is your vision
leave it down the comments below I'm
really curious to find out thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you
I hope continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one where it is much
love I'll see you soon and enjoy the
bonus the first one that most people
come to me is they don't have a clear
vision of what they want they want a
better life they want to make more money
they want to have a better relationship
but they're not clear and the greatest
minds and the greatest achievers are
very specific and clear on their vision
it's so certain to them what it is they
can see it they can feel it they can
taste it and as an athlete I used to
visualise how one of the creates my
sport I wanted to create myself in
sports and vision was very powerful for
me back then as it is now for business
world so the first thing is vision that
people need to get clear on started with
vision in sports we always start each
season with a clear vision on the
chalkboard in the locker room what are
we looking to achieve this season do we
want to make the playoffs do we want to
win the championship we're always very
clear it's written up on the board every
day walking a law firm we see our vision
we know what we're working towards so
for me I have a board with my vision and
every day I look at it and I'm very
clear and specific about what it is when
it's gonna happen each six months to a
year each season of my life so I just
try to translate all that I learn as an
athlete because that's all I knew into
life and it's helping me get to at least
where I'm at currently
once long yeah the most important work
ever if you had to think of one word
that's most important to you or that
sums you Apple that would be to like a
little beacon pay believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]